foreign
[Music]
the visualized edition of the backstage
podcast bringing you all of the latest
interviews and reviews from the world of
film and television and joining me it's
Skye's entertainment reporter Claire
Greg hello hello and Skype Skype sir
Jason mansory hello we can't talk
it's a very busy week we're bringing you
a very very Starry show this week all of
the the stars of Tinseltown have been uh
with us this week talking to us here on
the podcast here's what's coming up
I can't lose my license
before we get on to some of the major
major a-listers that we've been talking
to this week we have to talk Oscars
first this is a rumor this isn't
actually confirmed yet but it seems
there could be a stunt Oscar coming our
way
something that's been rumored for a
while talked about there's been a lot of
call for air as well as casting Oscar
these are kind of areas that feel like
they're not current winner does a
forward roll and a handstand it would
make for some thrilling footage at least
during the ceremony I'd say that much
and I mean one of the key winners would
surely be Mr Tom Cruise oh how
interesting well it just so happens
he has been in town this week and I was
fortunate enough to catch up with him
because of course the big big
Blockbuster releases coming up in July
at the new latest Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one uh we have to
stress and we can't really give you any
reviews at the moment because we've all
signed bits of paperwork that says we're
not allowed to but safe to say it's
action-packed action-packed my hands
went numb I was so clutching my face for
the two hours worth of film that I
forgot to kind of move my limbs but
without saying anything what we can say
is that I did get to have a very good
chat with Mr Tom Cruise mic drop there
um who was his fabulous self talking to
everyone at the the London Leicester
Square Premiere and here's what he had
to say to me the thing about these films
is you watch one and you think they're
not going to be able to Trump the next I
mean how do you do this how do you
Workshop this you know it's mchu and I
and we just constantly push each other
never rest on your morals after every
film that we have tonight I'll probably
say it to him again when it's done when
I turn around and go we can do better
and that's how I feel about about
everything that I do tell us about day
one of shooting when you get on a
motorcycle go off of the cliff six
seconds before you might hit the ground
what did you even have time to question
what you're doing you know there's been
honestly there's some when I train
there's so much going on that time
expands
when I'm dropping at six seconds
feels longer and Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one comes out in cinemas
on July the 10th and we will of course
talk a bit more about that on the longer
podcast if you want to to check out and
have a listen to that at some point
probably next week not this week because
of all of the paperwork that we've
signed
but moving on let's talk about something
that we can talk in a bit more detail
about um Wes Anderson is back with
another star-studded film it's one of
the most talked about Indie offerings of
the summer and it's asteroid City
I don't like the way that guy looked at
us the alien
like we're doomed
[Music]
how long can they keep us an asteroid
City legally the world will never be the
same Claire look this is one that we've
been talking about for quite a while
well of course when you see the trailer
it's so star-studded isn't it it's
absolutely gorgeous looking and that's
even before you put all these Mega stars
in it as you say in huge cast list
you've got people like Tom Hanks uh
Scarlett Johansson Brian Cranston Tilda
Swinton Jeffrey Wright and the list goes
on and we haven't got enough time right
now for me to literally list everyone
but this is interesting because it's
like a film within a film with it it's a
play within a TV special it's very weird
it's actually built a functioning town
in Spain in order for everyone to kind
of live together and work together while
making this they filmed this during
lockdown can you imagine being in a
lockdown bubble with Ryan Cranston Jason
Schwartzman uh Scarlett Johansson quite
a bubble isn't it the film itself is
about set in 1950s America
um Southwest America and it's about a
kind of convention where people get
together to celebrate the anniversary of
a meteorite Landing in this small town
um in Southwest U.S and they're all
there for this stargazing contest when
an actual alien turns out what are the
chances none of that really matters
remember that really matters because it
looks beautiful it looks beautiful the
palette of colors is incredible but the
only thing I take up is everyone
describes this as the Indie filmmaker
where's Anderson as just as a director
has grossed over 280 million across
these films already let's we're Beyond
him being we don't need to say he's
gonna do all right
look at the list of actors they're in it
I just think it's important to well it's
quite a list and we were fortunate
enough on the the podcast to catch up
with a few of those Stars including
Brian Cranston who plays the narrator I
was influenced by Ted Koppel and uh and
I I sort of love the way he delivered
the news and I I also feel that those
men
fall in love with their own voices and
here it is you know there's yes so that
sort of came to me that we would do it
in this sort of registry and without any
emotion and without any opinion on what
I was saying so that the actors in the
group can supply that I was just there
to monitor and feed in Exposition and
Scarlett Johansson uh spoke to the
podcast about preparing for such a such
a meta role the prep was more
um maybe it was more
like involved
um with this one because it had so many
different layers
um
you know sometimes I don't always if I
go into doing something I try to come in
with something to hang my hat on so I
have something to offer in the beginning
and then it hopefully will evolve from
there but this had this it needed
a bit of a bit of kind of thinking on it
and discussion with Wes and a lot of
questions and stuff like that asteroid
city is out in cinemas now can we also
talk on the podcast this week maybe
shoehorn another celebrity in here
in our 10 minutes
um Jennifer Lawrence she's back on the
big screen with her new film uh no hard
feelings he's just been so worried about
our son he's going to Princeton in the
fall no I've heard of it you know we
tried everything to bring him out of his
shell he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls he doesn't drink
so when you say date him do you mean
date him or date him yes datum date him
hard I'll date his brains out Claire
tell us a little bit about what this
one's about then well almost
unbelievably this is based on a real
Craigslist ad which is a listing site in
the US so uh no in the film Jennifer
Lawrence plays a woman she's absolutely
broke she's about to lose her car which
is bad news because she's an Uber driver
um and she finds an intriguing job ad
which is for it's been posted by some
parents who are looking for someone to
date and in fact sleep with their very
introverted 19 year old son who they
think needs to come out of his shell
before he goes off to college so she's
basically got the summer to try and
seduce him and if she does it they'll
give her this lovely card that's wild
that was a real crazy
absolutely Bonkers
um and this is Jennifer Lawrence kind of
much as being made of the fact this is
her first big lead in a comedy uh she's
kind of rose to fame doing drama so
something slightly different for her
although you know we've seen her in
interviews and things like that we kind
of know that she's that's my point I
feel like I don't understand why this
hasn't happened before and why anyone's
surprised if you look at a demeanor the
way she acts the way she talks it makes
absolute sense well we go into a bit
more detail on the podcast don't we but
hilariously Claire she was so running to
such time wasn't she
basically unheard of for celebrities to
be on time and Jennifer Lawrence was not
only on time but ahead of schedule so I
was left running uh to literally running
to get to get to this interview in order
to be there to speak to her so hence why
I might look slightly flustered when I
uh when I caught up with her has comedy
been playing a bit safe maybe is it
about time for something like this mean
I feel that way personally I think I
mean
boy it's just been sad in New York like
our sky was just like brown yeah and you
know children couldn't go outside I
think it's time for just like a good
old-fashioned laugh and it really is
hard to make a comedy where you're not
offending people yeah everybody in some
sense will be offended by this film no
hard feelings is in cinemas now
no hard feelings gang
we've got to go this is the end of the
visualized uh podcast but if you've
liked what you've listened to today
there is the longer version of the
podcast itself where you get much more
of the interviews of the people that
we've heard from today and much more of
our reviews do take a listen you can
just uh scan the QR code on our screens
now or look for the podcast wherever it
is you get your regular podcasts from
this is uh backstage and we'll talk to
you again very soon thank you Claire
thank you Jason thank you very much
thank you we'll see you again very soon